son ton petit rocher là juste en face si
son soigneur le cycle comme on
appellerait un animal de compagnie il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il s'adresse au roi
de la savane avec ses 250 kg kruger
c'est la star de la fauverie au zoo de
beauval avec le reste de la famille il a
quitté son ancien territoire pour un
plus grand de 5300 mètres carrés il y a
quelques jours un changement
d'environnement qui nécessite un temps
d'adaptation on peut pas les déménager
comme ça est leur ouvrir il ferait un
peu perdu donc il ya toujours un peu
près une semaine voire quinze jours à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
comme ça ils s'acclimatent au bâtiment
et puis bah après une fois qu'ils sont
bien acclimatés à leur enclos on
commence à faire des petites sorties
tout en laissant quand même ouvert comme
ça ils peuvent se mettre à l'intérieur
et se mettent à l'extérieur comme ils
veulent dérougi en hauteur pour dominer
l'espace une cascade mais aussi des
cachettes sous de grosses pierres
le nouvel habitat des félins tentent
d'imiter leur milieu naturel c'était le
souhait du directeur de l'établissement
nos animaux peuvent aussi se soustraire
de la vue du public
c'est important ils ne sont pas en
exposition si on peut dire en permanence
ils doivent pouvoir avoir des zones de
repli des zones à eux au public ne les
voit pas donc le public doit être
parfois patients l'espace qui a coûté 4
5 millions d'euros est désormais assez
grand pour accueillir de nouveaux
pensionnaires et ça tombe bien puisque
quatre nouveau nés ont vu le jour il ya
quelques semaines
toujours en observation ils devraient
faire leurs premiers pas sur la terre
des lions le mois prochain